hey guys it is the 19th of May today my
name is Jess and you are watching games
buttons even though just days ago take
to said that rockstar games would be
announcing new project soon they've now
said that those games won't actually be
out until well into 2017 during a text
to earnings call CEO Strauss Zelnick
said rockstar did not plan to release a
new game in the current fiscal year
which means no new games until at least
April 2017 that said there's a good
chance we'll hear about them well before
then take two also recently teased that
rockstar has big plans for III so we
might get that red dead redemption
sequel after all or at least remaster
the publisher also confirmed they are
working on new IP but it's not known
whether rockstar is developing it
granturismo sport has a brand new
trailer and a release date the latest in
the PlayStation exclusive racing sim
series will come to ps4 on November 15
in Japan Asia and North America followed
by in November 18 launched in the UK the
info dropped as part of a special event
showcasing the game under his most
bought was first announced last October
where they were originally plans for a
beta version early this year and VR
support but there was no mention of
either in today's announcement you can
check out the car tastic trailer and
screenshots in our story on site
Microsoft has announced they're bringing
halo 5s forge tools to PC later this
year the tools will enable players to
create levels on Windows 10 pcs and
publish them on Xbox one it's worth
noting now this isn't the halo 5 game
it's just the tool set to make maps and
such aside from the regular features
you'll get with halo 5 sports tools
you'll also get keyboard and mouse
support as well as
this resolution microsoft have made the
tool set free on Windows 10 so if you're
keen to build an app for halo 5 on the
pc you can go ahead and do that when
this one arrives in the common mult let
me know down in that comment box if your
aim that creation thin and be sure to
stop by gamespot when we've got stories
understand it too and crash then Pete
that is everything I've got for you
today but be sure to come by same time
to work for the five biggest stories of
the entire week I'll see you then